[Applaudissements]
durée toi
du coup tu l'a jamais vu la variante
dans mon cul
[Applaudissements]
si vous reprenez l'antenne jeu sur
cognac jay je serai là et peut-être même
nu voilà qui secoue penser des
transports en commun des transports en
commun parisiens
ouais que du bien du bien et votre frère
elle en pense quoi votre frère vous êtes
déjà ramené mon frère il en pense quoi
votre frère bas du bien je pense votre
frère ils en pensent quoi des transports
parisiens malo
merci moi faire la surprise avec camille
il ya quelqu'un qui a souhaité vous
faire une surprise ce soir elle est là
tu as ta rentrée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'idée c'est un mou avec toi c'est mon
prof de chant jack était à sanaa ou pas
[Applaudissements]